good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I was
talking to a friend at VidCon actually I
wasn't talking to him I was scrolling
through my Twitter feed trying to make
sure that everyone was having a good
time at VidCon you know and looking to
see if there were any problems and my
friend said you seemed stressed and I
said Twitter which is both the name of a
social network and my personal word for
that kind of buzzing misery that the
social internet lately fills me with I
call this strange brew of outrage and
worry and exhaustion and not being able
to look away twittering but presumably
you can get the same unpleasant and yet
still somehow desirable feeling from
other social media outlets and also
possibly elsewhere but I get it mostly
from Twitter by the way I hope you don't
get this feeling and that the internet
brings you nothing but joy and
fulfillment I think Twitter and Facebook
and etc are useful and important and in
pockets quite beautiful and obviously
I've benefited from them a lot but I'm
just gonna level with you and
acknowledge that the majority of time
these days my general feeling when on
the social Internet is like ah right so
anyway I explained this to my friend and
he said you should make your phone into
a dumb phone and I said what and then he
explained that among the many things you
can do with the smart phone is turn it
into a device that closely resembles the
cell phone from 2005 except with a much
better camera this had literally never
occurred to me and about a month later
after a particularly egregious episode
of twittering I did it my phone no
longer has Twitter or Facebook or email
or reddit I even broke my son's heart by
deleting pokemons go I do still have an
internet browser which allows me to fall
down various rabbit holes if I'm highly
motivated but in general I just used my
phone for calls and texting and pictures
well also I've got my Delta app so I can
check into flights and Yelp and Google
Maps and of course the Chipotle app and
this app that tells me whether there are
soccer games on TV right now it's not
really that dumb of a phone but the
point is I have no way of twittering
there's just one problem with my dumb
phone which is that it hasn't worked
like I suppose in the last 7 months my
background level of stress has decreased
somewhat but mostly I just spend more
time with my computer this is partly
because I feel some vague but nagging
obligation to be informed about the
events of the day although in the end
I'm not convinced that twittering
actually makes me better informed like I
know quite a lot about Donald Trump's
handshakes with foreign leaders but I
don't know much about South Korea's
ousted president or the ongoing
corruption scandals in Brazil or even
the US Federal Reserve's monetary policy
plus I feel like when I'm inside the
feed I kind of become a person I dislike
like I find myself skimming instead of
engaging and valuing cleverness over
compassion and also clicking on
clickbait which just creates a world
with more clickbait and sometimes I'll
be like sorry my actual real life family
but someone is wrong about something on
the internet and I need to explain to
them exactly why they are wrong god help
me I've even retweeted fake news point
being it is time for a drastic
intervention so in the last couple weeks
I've decided to scale way back on the
social Internet and put myself on an
information diet rather than trying to
drink from the fire hose of Twitter I'm
spending an hour or two each morning
reading these mostly The Economist the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
and my hometown Indianapolis Star how do
I explain newspapers and magazines to
young people basically it's like a very
carefully curated internet that someone
prints on paper and then mails to your
house it's an extremely inefficient
process and too expensive but I am
desperate for a change so is it working
well I'll echo many a clickbait science
headline and say that early results are
positive but it's too soon to know for
sure nerdfighters i'm curious if you're
having similar problems with the social
internet or if my experience is more of
an outlier let me know in the comments
below on that subject I will say that
YouTube still feels different to me from
the rest of the Internet in general I
just find YouTube less stressful but
that might be because I get to live in
this relatively friendly and peaceful
corner of it so thank you for that Hank
I'll see you on Friday